one of the most remarkable aspects of
the modernist movement in architecture
was the idea that buildings should
pretty much look the same wherever on
earth they happen to be the key early
figures of modernism were united in
their opposition to any kind of regional
architecture which they saw as
reactionary folkloric and mediocre the
Brazilian architect Oscar Niemeyer began
his career as an orthodox modernist he
was born in Rio de Janeiro in 1907 and
developed a passion for architecture in
his early teens as a young man he fell
in with a group that venerated the great
european modernist architects especially
luca brasi
who had insisted on making sure that
buildings made no concession whatsoever
to the culture in which they happen to
be located Niemeyer's professional
dreams were realized when in 1936 lucca
brizia came to Rio to design the new
ministry of education and health and
Niemeyer got a job on the project while
working with him nehemiah retained the
utmost respect for look obviously but at
the same time he couldn't help but
observe how blind his guest was to the
particularity 's of Brazilian culture
and climate with what would become his
legendary charm
Niemeyer managed to persuade locals year
to abandon some of his more hard-edged
Universalist ideas and to start to make
some concessions to local conditions
under Niemeyer's influence the
building's windows acquired shades
against the Sun and even an enormous
traditional Portuguese piece of tile
work done up with beautiful abstract
motifs for the public areas on the
ground floor emboldened by his success
nehemiah felt ready to break free from
European modernism he is now celebrated
for being the first modernist architect
anywhere in the world to practice a
regional kind of modernism in his case a
Brazilian infused modernism his first
wholly original work was completed in
1943 when he was 36
the Church of st. Francis of Assisi in
Belo Horizonte the church had no
straight lines on any plane for Niemeyer
now judged these to be European and in
many ways authoritarian Niemeyer was
henceforth to include curves in all his
buildings and saw these in a
nationalistic light as being
particularly Brazilian in nature he
remarked what attracts me is the free
and sensual curve the curve that I find
in the mountains of my country in the
sinuous course of its rivers and in the
bodies of beautiful Brazilian women the
latter point about women is telling me
Maya was deeply responsive to female
beauty throughout his life he was famous
around Rio for his affairs many with
people dramatically younger than he was
at 92 he acquired a girlfriend
who just turned 25 as in the Ministry of
Health the PAMP Euler church had tiles
across it they reminded viewers that
Brazil could be both modern and yet
recall its heritage that a church might
nod towards the forms of a futuristic
airplane hangar and yet could at the
same time accommodated a picture of
Saint Francis Nehemiah's most audacious
attempt to define Brazilian identity
came with his designs for the new
capital Brasilia in 1956 president
kubacheck of Brazil asked Niemeyer to
help create a wholly planned city in the
center of the country free from the
corruption of the old capital in Rio
Niemeyer drew up the National Congress a
Cathedral a cultural complex many
ministries and commercial and
residential buildings the atmosphere was
dignified hopeful and in touch with a
native environment apartment buildings
were often lifted on stilts to allow
vegetation to grow beneath them
maintaining a connection with a local
ecology and tropical climate of course
Nima's works depicted Brazil not as it
was but as he believed and hoped it
might one day be Brasilia imagines the
Brazil of the future it's a glass and
reinforced concrete ideal for the
country to develop towards in the future
so the capital argues Brazil will be a
place where rationality is powerful
where order and harmony reign and where
elegance and serenity
normal nehemiah was prolific until the
very last years teaching around the
world writing and designing sculptures
and furniture he died in 2012 when he
was a hundred and four years old he was
given a hero's funeral and thousands
joined the cortege what his nation was
honoring was an architect who had given
it a workable yet ideal portrait of
itself
he'd enabled Brazil to break free from a
sterile European modernism and to create
buildings that better reflected the
nation's uniqueness Niemeyer remains an
example to all architects who aspire to
put up buildings that remember the
distinctiveness of their locations
Architects who may like their computers
or their phones to be Universal in
design but are as keen for their
buildings to be culturally specific
thank you for watching remember to like
the video and please subscribe to our
channel for more
you